so I have to mention this you've
probably seen it by now but uh I'm oh
look I'm a sucker for heartwarming
videos uh I just am that may surprise
you to learn about me but I I'm uh yeah
I I I love the heartwarming like anytime
I see one of those videos that comes up
um on the feed of uh you know like a a
young child getting a hearing aid for
the first time and hearing his mother's
voice for the first time uh very
heartwarming I always stop and watch
those videos
to warm my cold dead heart and
um
but of all the heartwarming videos I've
seen online in recent weeks I think none
were quite so
um so nice as this one let's let's watch
it together
[Music]
did anyone get that yeah
we're gonna
stay
together
[Music]
the ground
don't move
[Music]
[Applause]
uh sorry I'm getting a little emotional
uh like I said I'm just I'm a sucker for
these kinds of videos so that was the
that was the Tribal Police in Nevada
dealing with climate protesters who are
blocking the highway and as you can see
they just Ram right through the
barricade they throw the protesters on
the ground cuff them drag them off
while they cry and whine we're
non-violent
it's just fantastic to see and there are
a bunch of other videos like this from
different angles
um and you could see the whole
interaction it's fantastic I love every
second of it it's worth watching all of
it
and the great thing is that the
protesters themselves are the ones who
filmed this and posted it
thinking that we would sympathize with
them
that we would watch this and go look at
what those mean police did
that's terrible
except except that literally everyone
who saw these videos said wow that's
awesome good for those cops that's great
well done
and this is how cops should deal with
these clowns everywhere no patience no
mercy
throw them in cuffs and drag them away
ran through the barricades uh and just
deal with them like that it's all great
and it's great because for one thing
okay blocking the road is not
non-violent you are using physical Force
you're using your own bodies to impede
the movements of thousands of people
that is not non-violent
and you have no idea where those
thousands of people are going or where
they need to be they could be going to
the hospital with a sick child
you know you don't know not to mention
you're trapping all these people in in
their cars in in the heat out in the
desert
so yeah that's a violent act and it
should be treated as such
before giving our dog rough grains he
was so sad and lazy well now he actually
enjoys his squeaky toys and playing
Fetch with his frisbee our pup stays are
filled with laughter exercise and
endless fun naturopathic Dr Dennis black
the founder of rough grants is focused
on improving the health of every dog in
America little did I know before I got
rough greens dog food is dead food
everybody knows that nutrition isn't
Brown it's green well rough greens boost
your dog's food back to life rough
grains is a supplement that contains all
the necessary vitamins minerals
probiotics Omega oils digestive enzymes
and antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food just sprinkle rough grains on their
food every day dog owners everywhere are
raving about rough greens supports
healthy joints improves bad breath
boosts energy levels and so much more we
are what we eat and that goes for dogs
too naturopathic Dr Dennis black is so
confident rough grains will improve your
dog's health he's offering my listeners
a free jump start trial bag so your dog
can try it a free jumpstart trial bag
can be at your door in just a few
business days go to roughgreens.com Matt
or call 844 rough seven that's
ruffgreens.com Matt or call 844 rough
700 today notice something else and
really take note of this
everybody loves the fact that these cops
are just shutting these a-holes down
everyone loves it
there was a there's a climate protester
group called climate Defiance and they
posted uh that video that I just showed
you with an outraged caption that says
words fail words utterly fail today a
police truck plowed into a peaceful
climate blockade these are the people
entrusted to keep us safe these are the
people we've granted a monopoly on the
use of force how is this okay
and the thing is every single comment
responding to that post every single one
was like it's okay with me
looks great to me
that's how everyone feels
okay if you were to put this video in
front of all 330 million people in the
country it's guaranteed that at least
329 million 999
993 of them
would love the video
very close to 100 percent
and why is that
well because the average person is sick
of this
they're just sick of it
um you know I think like 10 years ago
maybe
that same exact video might get a
slightly I think still most people would
be on the side of the cops but there
might be a few more people who would see
that video 10 years ago and say oh that
was a little excessive come on you don't
have to do that
um but these days people are sick
they're tired of the lawlessness they're
tired of these kinds of jerks
interfering with your day for no reason
uh they're tired of people who make your
life harder and more miserable just
because they can
they're tired of the lack of
accountability the fact that you know
people just do whatever they want
and the law is not enforced
they're sick of it
and they're ready for uh some some uh
some tough love some some Rough and
Tumble
that's what they're ready for
and I think Republican politicians would
do well to take note of that
that is the the mood that's the national
mood right now
one where people just want Law and Order
that's what they want
that's what we should always want
but uh especially now that's what people
want
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there